sa le matin il dégoûté de se lever pour
dire qu'on travaille durement ouis je me
lève avec le sourire en fait et ma fille
je veux qu'elle se lève avec le sourire
en fait pouro je me lever oh je
vais au travail aujourd'hui je suis
dégoûté c'est ça c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça dans cette émission il y a thry Moron
ave chroniqueur PMP qui qui en plus qui
éta à la place de la potich à l'époque
[Rires]
euh c'est vrai au
fonditetiche voilà comme ça et il a
dit et donc comme je l'avais comme je
l'avais un peu secoué la semaine
dernière tel un
Orangina il a il a affirmé que il a
voulu se venger donc il a dit dans
l'émission qu'il a affirmé que je
donnais des consignes stricts pour les
chroniqueurs et que lui décidait de de
ne pas les respecter donc lui moi je
donnais des consignes et lui lui c'est
le rebelle c'est Lorenzo laamasse il
était flic il faisait du bon boulot non
mais frère le rebelle de la bande donc P
donc il est arrivé ilit tête contre tête
contre com ouais je t'exp je vais pas le
dire ouais qu'est-ce qui t'arrive gen on
était en tête contre- tête dans la loge
il mettait des coups de pression pendant
7 ans tous c 7 ans il mettaient des
petits coups des petits coups de T ici
comme ça tu vois donc voilà donc th le
rebelle donc il a dit que lui il ne
suivait pas les les consignes et il a
dit que j'avais demandé à une époque de
de défoncer Arthur c'est qu'il a dit et
je me'en suis jamais caché non mais
c'est vrai moi je disais les choses ici
non mais les gars il nous parle d'un
truc j'ai j'ai juste j' avais des infos
qu'il n'avaient pas parce que Thierry
Morau il était président de il était
patron de Télé 7 Jours ou mais il avait
autant d'infos que ma mère à la
boucherie donc
regardez moi j'ai des souvenir très
précis de Cyril arrivant dans la loge
des chroniqueurs disant ce soir on va
désinguer Arthur alors après on suit on
suit pas les les consignes moi j'étais
pasatron Télé 7 Jours donc j'ai toujours
dit que je je je disais ce que je
voulais et je l'ai jamais désingué
gratuitement sauf quand je pensais que
l'émission n'était pas bonne une
émission mais on peut effectivement
suivre ce que nous demande de dire Cyril
on va parler de r dans un instant aussi
dans TPMP une nouvelle espèce de ragéon
vous allez voir ou
euh donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
phrase de Thierry ma Verdez ça me gêne
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi quand tu
l'aimes bien tu l'aimes bien et c'est
normal c'est je l'aimais bien donc il a
été là de 2010 à 2017 avant de faire
donc il a il a sorti un exemple voilà
ans en 7 ans et il faut savoir que comme
il dirigeait t les 7 jours d'ailleurs je
le chambrais à l'antenne il disait
globalement du mal enfin il critiquait
personne pourquoi il critiquait personne
parce que il pensait que les gens
pouvaient éventuellement être sur la Une
de Télé 7 Jours peu de temps après ou
avait fait la couverture peu de temps
avant donc du coup c'était robinet au
tiède donc lui vient nous donner des
leçons de on obéit à Cyril on obéit pas
à Cyril moi j'étais le rebelle c'est un
rebelle en carton quoi thry Morau il
s'est rebellé peut-être une fois parce
que son té était froid dans un
restaurant
mais à l'antenne j'ai pas souvenir d'une
intervention pertinente de Thierry Morau
ou d'une intervention où il critiqu à
quelqu'un donc th très sincèrement je
t'aime beaucoup mais ferme ta gueule
quoi c'est
trop il
est je l'aime bien en plus il para qu'il
ils l'ont pris dans complément d'enquête
et il para qu' avit parlé 2 heur ils ont
mis 40 secondes il parait qu'il avait
dit du bien oui Ky mais dans cette
histoire de Cyril qui nous dit ce qu'on
doit dire il y a un truc que je
comprends pas c'est qu'à partir du
moment où les personnes elles regardent
l'émission même ne ser qu'une seule fois
quand vous regardez Géraldine quand vous
regardez Gilles ouais peut-être Raymond
parfois mais vous êtes tout le temps en
train de vous embrouiller avec eux vous
êtes pas d'accord donc à partir de ce
moment-là on peut dire ce qu'on veut
mais en tout cas ça c'est juste
impossible et moi en tant que bonne
potiche ça fait 7 ans que j'ai pas lu un
seul conducteur je sais jamais de quoi
on va parler dans l'émission
c'est vra en plus donc là les gars là
vous foutez de ma gueule là c'est le
conducteur de vendredi par de parce que
je vois parce que je vous vois très dans
les loges en train de fumer tranquille
genre la meuf on dirait qu'elle a fait
son travail depuis 3 jours donc à partir
de ce momentl en fait vous foutez rien
qui m'a dit non mais non c'est pas ça
non j'en fais des caisses mais je parle
pas beaucoup avec la production c'est
vrai donc qui va nous dire ce qu'on doit
dire à partir de ce moment-là là ça fait
beaucoup d'exemples où à un moment donné
on peut pas nous dire ce qu'on va dire
si par avec ça fait des années qu'on a
pas reparlé d'Arthur va bien Chac tout
va bien après après juste pour le
défendre je trouve ça déjà bien quand
même qu'il s'exprime à visage découvert
au moins on a le mérite de pouvoir lui
répondre pas d'accord avec
toi je pense qu'il a dit n'importe quoi
mais au moins je je peux lui dire en
face Thierry Morau je suis pas d'accord
avec toi alors que ceux qui sont
toujours cachés avec des perruques des
lunettes qui disent oui on a dit qu'on a
dit qu'on a dit qu'on a dit bon benah ça
non merci non merci voilà non merci mais
c'est vrai qu'à priori dit plutôt du
bien de vous hein vraiment ou il est
gentil non tout temp entendu à la radio
je suis d'accord avec la radio je pout
un pe la radio paremp il préférait
largement quotidien à TP il a droit
c'est son
droitaim cche dans la souche qui était
là pendant 7 ans et qui maintenant
crache dans la soupe je préfère 100 fois
des Camille Combal des Jean-Luc Lemoin
des mecs sont partis ils ont jamais rien
dit ils ont ils ont accept ils ont
accepté pendant 7 ans ils sont restés là
ils ont fait leur beur ils ont fait leur
notorité après tu as des mecs comme
chameroi voilà c'est ça je trouve ça pas
pas clair en fait pas clair c'est pas
clair tu sais c'est pas clair mais voilà
mais tu sais vous vous souvenez de sa
sortie je vais te dire je vais te dire
c'est à la fin du bal qu'on paye la barv
r ça déjà il a raison g comment il est
parti souvenez de sorti tri je suis
Moren
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est c'est vrai et regardez où il est
maintenant le Pau franchement il est
dans une
émission arrê le voil on pas l'émission
arrê vouu
revenir les émissions sont GIR il a
demandé à revenir il avait demandé à
revenir il vouit faire pa avec
avec c'est oubl de
dire moi faut pas me casser la tête
après ça tombe ou moi voilàah oui tu
viens oui il faut pas venir m'attaquer
avec un couteau suisse les gars
non contradictoire puisquil il dit voilà
il prétend révéler quelque chose dont tu
dis de toute façon qu'il n'était pas
secret mais juste après il dit mais on
était libre de dire oui ou non donc en
fait ça veut dire qu'il y avait rien
écrit donc en fait il confirme le fait
que chacun est libre de dire ce qu'il
veut ouais oua
merci il y a pierre m qui a réagi sur le
complément d'enquête il a donné son avis
sur l'émission et notamment sur
l'interview de fin et il a témoigné
aussi en tant que chroniqueur de TPMP
regardez enchaîné les deux faire un un
documentaire faire aussi
long investir autant d'argent sur un
sujet c'est pas c'est pas la mission de
complément d'enquête et je pense que ces
gens-là sont extrêmement faux cul et qui
savaient très bien qu'en faisant une
heure sur Hanouna ils allaient cartonner
en audience j'ai trouvé l'interview de
de Booba à la fin très mauvaise très mal
menée et surtout avec la moitié des
questions sur Magalie ber et donc
totalement
sujet maintenant quand moi j'étais à
TPMP comme je l'ai dit dans un tweet
j'en ai fait 22 quand j'étais à TPMP
j'ai jamais eu de consignes pour savoir
euh pour me dire ce que ce que j'allais
dire il fallait parfois que je dise à
l'avance ce que je pensais sur des
sujets mais on m'a jamais dit
euh faut que tu dises ça ou ça de toute
façon si on prend dans une émission
j'ai la faiblesse de croire que c'est
quand même surtout pour ma liberté de
parole dit he très propr il a tout dit
c'est un amour pi moi j'ai j'adore ce
mec voilà vous le savez et voilà
j'espère qu'il rend bien très vite oui
je sais mais je l'aime
beaucoup justement parce qu'il y a plein
de gens qui vous disent aussi vous vous
gargarisez de ces drames qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ces gens je me gargarise
non mais pas vous voilà
les j'entends cet argument que je trouve
d'une d'une injustice terrible ça ma
motivation c'est simplement que j'ai
deux petites filles et que j'ai pas
envie qu'elles grandissent dans un pays
où elles peuvent se prendre un coup de
couteau sous la torfel parce qu'elle se
baladent dans la rue ou qu'elles vont à
un bal populaire et qu'en sortant à 2h
du matin elles se fassent massacrer par
par des racailles qui arrive avec des
couteaux de 25 cm donc moi je me lève le
matin pour ça donc si je me bats
politiquement c'est justement pour
essayer d'éiter ça et d'éviter ça quand
quand vous mettez un tweet ou quand vous
réagissez à telle ou telle attaque à tel
ou telle fait d'hiver est-ce que vous
vous tweetez en tant que mère de famille
d'abord ou en tant que femme
politique je suis une responsable
politique donc évidemment ma parole
publique c'est celle d'une responsable
politique maintenant mon moteur au
quotidien quand je me lève le matin pour
faire de la politique parisque vous
savez il y a pas que il y a pas toujours
des bons moments en politique he il y a
aussi des des sacrifices des contraintes
voilà les contraintes aussi de la vie
publique les contraintes de l'exposition
les contraintes parfois de l'agressivité
et de la menace ou de la mauvaise foi de
certains et donc en tout cas c'est c'est
mon moteur parce que c'est vrai que je
vous dis moi je en tant que maman je me
sens pas sereine aujourd'hui quand je me
lève le matin je me dis j'ai une fille
de 9 ans je me dis quand elle aura 12 ou
13 ans je ne sais pas comment je peux la
laisser aller dans le métro se balader
dans la rue aller de nuit faire la fête
je suis je je vois l'effondrement de mon
pays chaque jour je vois des drames de
plus en plus terribles vous l'avez dit
des choses qui n'existaient pas il y a
encore 30 ou 35 ans de ce que de d'un
temps que je n'ai pas connu mais dont on
me parlait et qui était un temps voilà
de paisible de de de cohésion de de
calme de sérénité qui n'existe plus
pourquoi je vous pose toutes ces
questions euh Marion maréchal c'est
parce que souvent euh les gens disent
oui euh les politiques ne parlent pas
avec leur cœur ne parlent pas avec leurs
sentiments mais ils parlent avec le à
des fins politiques à des fins
électorales quand ils font un tweet
quand on on l'a dit ça de autant de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon que d'Éric Zemour que
de voilà que de girald daranin ou que de
voilà tous les membres du gouvernement
ou est-ce que vous c'est pour ça ça que
je voulais savoir est-ce que vous vous
êtes vraiment vraiment touché quand
vraiment est-ce que vous dites voilà je
vais parler avec mon cœur et je vais
faire comme nous quand on tweet comme
tous les citoyens quand il tweet quand
il tweet quand il y a une attaque dit
moi je supporte plus mais moi Cyril
c'est vous savez j'ai arrêté la
politique en 2017 j'étais député
j'aurais pu à priori être quand même
facilement réélu j'avais voilà le le
tapis rouge dans le parti qui était le
mien à l'époque qui était le
rassemblement national j'ai quitté la
politique j'ai monté une entreprise j'ai
fait autre chose pendant 5 ans j'ai
décidé de revenir en politique et vous
m'accorderez que j'ai pas choisi la
facilité voilà j'ai choisi un un parti
naissant j'ai soutenu Éric Zemour et je
reconstruis aujourd'hui une une aventure
et une offre politique avec lui parce
que j'y crois parce que je défends des
idées mais je pourrais pour très bien
faire autre chose et j'ai fait autre
chose et je me suis très bien passé de
la vie publique pendant 5 ans donc oui
si je suis là aujourd'hui devant vous
c'est parce que je considère que la
situation et s'accélère et s'aggrave de
jour en jour et que je considère qu'il y
a pas aujourd'hui les réponses
politiques à la hauteur et et je ne vois
que rien ne change je considère qu'il y
a encore de l'aveuglement il y a du
dénis il y a du mensonge et donc
j'essayie à mon humble niveau de de de
d'apporter des solutions et et de tirer
on va dire l'opinion vers vers ces
solutions justement quand on dit à
chaque fois on dites vous les gens
disent la plus dangereuse à chaque fois
c'est Marion maréchal parce que elle a
un visage d'ange et elle peut faire
passer des idées voilà qui qui sont
parfois dures qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ces
gens moi j'ai si vous voulez la réalité
est dure la réalité est dure donc la
façon dont j'en parle mécaniquement est
dure et les solutions que je me propose
sont à la hauteur de de la gravité mais
je pense que ça n'est pas en cachant les
problèmes je pense que ça n'est pas en
les niant ou en ou en se détournant par
des manœuvres de diversion qu'on va y
répondre j'entends souvent un argument
que je trouve totalement Falaux en
disant mais oui vous vous voulez la
guerre civile vous voulez opposer les
gens vous voulez opposer les communautés
mais moi si je me bats tous les jours et
si j'essaie d'apporter des solutions
politiques et avant ça des diagnostics
parce que ce que Mo je ne veux pas de la
guerre civile je ne veux pas de la
guerre ethnique je ne veux pas de la
guerre religieuse ça me terrifie ça
m'inquiète parce que qui va être les
victimes de cette guerre si un jour elle
éclate ce sont mes enfants moi je le
verrai peut-être même pas donc en fait
je tout ce que je fais et et quand je
pose des termes parfois dures sur une
situation dure c'est justement pour
éviter cette dérive et ce que je
constate c'est que tous ceux aujourd'hui
qui m'opposent ces arguments et qui
m'attaquent avec ces arguments sont
précisément ceux qui ont mis en place
toutes les conditions qui ont entraîné
la situation qui existe aujourd'hui donc
je pense que c'est voilà c'est c'est un
argument une fois de plus de mauvaise
foi qui qui est un argument presque
presque moral pour ne pas avoir à
répondre sur le fond en fait alors on va
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé samedi
soir en plein Paris un homme muni d'un
couteau et d'un marteau a attaqué
plusieurs personnes dont un touriste qui
est décédé de ses blessures un touriste
allemand qui était là avec sa copine
voilà qui vous rendez compte vous rendez
compte comment rendez compte voilà par
exemple quel touriste va venir
aujourd'hui à Paris non mais franchement
quand vous entendez cette histoire il
est venu d'Allemagne il est venu passer
un weekend avec sa
fiancée c'est son anniversaire non mais
non mais vous rendez compte de
çaag vous rendez compte de ça il y on va
faire les Jos là dans 8 mois va faire
les Jos là en juin là on est prêt à
faire les Jos là non on n pas prêt des
gars excusez-moi il a la police fait
très bien son travail en plus je tiens à
le dire mais aujourd'hui on est gars
c'est pas possible vous rendez compte
aujourd'hui quand on va à l'étranger je
vous jure que c'est vrai avant moi quand
je suis allé en vacances on me disait ne
va jamais au Brésil c'est très dangereux
aujour'hui les gens disent ne va jamais
en France c'est très dangereux vous
rendez compte comment parle les les les
autres pays c'est incroyable c'est c'est
fou alors cette histoire donc lui P pvre
garçon et ça P fancé ils viennent pour
son
anniversaire en plein Paris il y a un
homme donc armé d'un couteau et d'un
marteau qui attaque plusieurs personnes
Michel Marie vous allez nous raconter
les les faits dans un instant le
terroriste était fichess radicalisé en
plus d'avoir de très gros de très gros
troubles psychiatriques et d'être suivi
de près par les renseignements par les
services de renseignement on va regarder
la vidéo de l'attaque filmée par des
passants et on en parle juste après on
d'abord revenir sur les faits et Marion
maréchal vous aurez une proposition de
loi à faire et vous nous direz ce que
vous en pensez de cette proposition de
lo ce que je pense on s'est tous posé la
question le dimanche après s'est tous
posé la même question vous allez nous
poser dans un
[Musique]
instant de braquer un
mec ah oui il
est posle s'il te plaît
arrête là il a fait une dinguerie de
ouf regarde là il a il a pété le visage
à un mec là en passant
là quand vous avez appris samedi soir
cet attentat vous avez réagi comment
mais je en fait je sais plus on arrive
plus à savoir si on est sidéré triste en
colère moi j'ai une forme de révolte je
vais pas vous mentir parce que là je en
arrivant chez vous refait la liste un
peu de tous ceux qui aujourd'hui avaient
commis des attentats il y a eu 56
attentats depuis 2012 donc c'est assez
phénoménal ceux qui étaient fichés c'est
exactement comme vous le dire c'est
qu'il étaé identifié par l'État et suivi
par l'État pour radicalisation islamiste
je vais vous faire un petit rappel parce
que c'est quand même assez terrifiant
l'attentat du Talis en 2015 fiché s le
massacre du Battal clan 2015 l'un d'eux
était fiché s l'assassinat du pèreamel
il était fiché s la tentative d'attentat
sur les ChampsÉlysées c'est fich s le
terrorisme de l'Opéra fiché s l'attentat
du marché de Noël à Strasbourg fich s le
l'ASS Berard F l'attent aujourd'huiour F
et là non exorci donc ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
où on a un état et vous avez raison de
le rappeler avec des forces de l'ordre
des de renseignement qui font leur
travail qui identifient des gens qui les
suivent et pour autant on voit bien que
ces gens restent en liberté et donc moi
la conclusion à laquelle j'arrive
justement vous allez faire votre
proposition oui aujourd'hui c'està-d
qu'on a 5000 vous l'avez rappelé 5000
personnes qui sont parmi les plus
dangereux donc fichiers pour islamisme
qui menace la vie 76 millions de
Français on a l'impression qu'on doit
attendre chaque jour qu'il assassin ou
égor
isistep précaution pour l'environnement
il a existé un principe de précaution
pour le covid où là personne n'a rien
trouvé à redire pour enfermer
l'intégralité de la population chez elle
qu'il faut avoir un principe de
précaution vis-à-vis de ces bombes à
retardement identifié comme tel et suivi
pour cela c'est-à-dire qu'il faut une
arrestation immédiate et une détention
préventive de tous les fichiers
aujourd'hui en France pour les
neutraliser et neutraliser leur
dangerosité le temps d'étudier au cas
par cas chacune des situations
neutraliser comment comment vous
c'estàdire il faut les mettre en centre
de rétention détenenstion provisoire
avant le passage à l'acte mais il faut
qu'on les ait je ve dire un ça devrait
priorité de l'État l'État devrait penser
à ça matin midi et soir Marion Marichal
5000 places aujourd'hui en prison ou en
en préventif CRE de r centre de rétion
on les pas si l'État est capable
aujourd'hui de répartir sur l'ensemble
du territoire des dizaines de milliers
de mineurs isolés ou de migrants je
pense qu'il est capable aujourd'hui de
réquisitionner des lieux pour pouvoir en
urgence mettre ces personnes dans des
centres de posons la question au
téléspectateurs ouais et donc
neutraliser le temps une fois de plus
qu'il soit étudié au cas par cas parce
que soit ce sont des étrangers légaux et
ou des clandestins et dans ce gar ils
doivent être expulsés mais les délais
d'expulsion sont tellement longs que le
temps que ce soit traité ils sont des
menaces soit ce sont des binationaux et
dans ce cas c'est le cas notamment
d'ailleurs de de celui qui a frappé
samedi dernier ils doivent être déchus
de leur nationalité française et
également expulsé mais tout ça prend du
temps donc le temps une FO plus que les
procédures aboutissent ils doivent être
mis hors d'état de nuire et soit ils
sont français et dans ce cas-là il faut
donner le temps d'aller voir dans ses
profils et dans leur environnement ce
qui peut entraîner des condamnations
pour ensuite les les protéger le citoyen
alors Mario Mario marchalust on a
l'impression que là ça s'accélère de
plus en plus à chaque fois qu'il y a un
drame c'est un ficher S c'est vrai on a
l'impression que en fait c'est fich S
c'est c'est quoi on a l'impression que
fichers S c'est juste avant de commettre
un DRAM on est fich S et vous vous avez
raison parce que faut regarder le genre
de profil qui se balade aujourd'hui et
qui sont fichers s je regardais tout à
l'heure là le 6 octobre dernier il y a
l'avocat thbaau de Montbrial je sais pas
si vous voyez qui est un avocat
médiatique connu et engagé dans la lutte
justement contre l'islamisme il a été
menacé au cours d'une instance de
décapitation par un fichier s qui est
bien connu alors là j'ai son CV c'est
quand même assez édifiant donc le type a
été six fois signalisé à la justice il a
contribué à la radicalisation du
assassin des policiers de mananville il
a été interpellé en route vers un camp
d'entraînement pour devenir djihadiste
il a été condamné d'ailleurs par le
passé pour des faits liés au terrorisme
aujourd'hui cet homme il travaille il
est libre il touche les APL voilà donc
voilà le genre de profil aujourd'hui qui
est dans la nature et donc ce genre de
profil ne doit pas être dans la nature
il doit être en détention sair ce qu'on
fait de posose à nos téléspectateurs et
là et ce que vous proposez c'est donc
tous les fichs donc les 5000 fichs les
mettre dans un centre de de de de
détentiontion pour une raison très
simple c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous l'avez
rappelé d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on dit
on peut pas mettre un policier derrière
chacun d'eux aujourd'hui il y a 5000
fichiers s aujourd'hui il y a un peu
plus de 4500 personnes de la DGSI donc
ils ne sont pas en mesure matérielle
humaine de pouvoir suivre 24 heures sur
24 et 7 jours sur 7 ces personnes il y a
un syndicat j'ai vu ça dans Le Parisien
témoignage de syndicat de policier qui
disait que si on voulait suivre
efficacement ces personnes il faudrait
qu'il a entre 10 et 12 policiers par
personne fich est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord ou pas avec la proposition
ouii oui non s'il vous plaît oui non oui
non non oui Daniel oui oui ben non non
parce que pour la simple et bonne raison
que vous savez que c'est pas pas
faisable en tout cas en l'état des
chos pas dire fa cette proposition a
déjà été faite en
2016 arrê avec ça on s'en fout on s'en
fout soit pas constitionn les Français
vous croyez qu'ils veulent sentendre
c'est pas constitutionnel
la détention préventive elle existe dans
plusieurs cas elle existe dans la
rétention de sûreté après une
condamnation existe par exemple dans
l'hospitalisation d'office justement sur
le cas psychiatrique elle existe dans la
signation à résidence donc elle existe
aujourd'hui dans un certain nombre de
cas à partir du moment où il y a un
contrôle du juge et ce que reproche le
Conseil d'État à l'époque c'est dans la
proposition qui a été qu'il n'y a pas de
contrôle du juge donc peôle du juge des
libertés qui puisse en effet
régulièrement réévaluer la situation
croyz que le le le le jeune Allemand là
qui est mort là samedi soir on va lui
dire le Conseil constitutionnel ne veut
pas raisonner à droit constant c'est
S auourd'hui il fa ch qui ch on part du
principe qu'il y a des drames qui
s'accumulent de semaine en semaine on a
vu fich fich fich un moment si on prend
des décisions ou bien on continue comme
ça et on va tous les toutes les semaines
on va recevoir Mar
maréchal magaliie qu'est-ce que vous
pensez vous de ces réquisitions donc
prison ferme pour certains non moi je
les ai trouvé très justes ça a été très
bien éayé par par la procureur en plus
donc il y a eu 13 prévenus pour
l'instant qui ont comparu et il y a 13
peines de prison qui ont été requises
donc ça prouve ça donne un signal très
fort aujourd'hui sur la prise en compte
du cyber harcèlement en France avec la
création du pnlh du parquet national de
la de la de la haine en ligne et et les
choses changent et je pense que les
choses changent donc quelle que soit la
décision qui en ressortira pour moi
c'est un signal très fort qui vient de
de d'être passé oui c'est bien qu'il y a
de la prison ferme parce que on a
tendance à banaliser le harcèlement en
ce moment tout est du harcèlement la
Magalie elle a vraiment vécu un
harcèlement terrible envers sa famille
avec des messages insistants des vagues
des raides numériques donc c'est très
bien je voulais vous demander est-ce que
vous avez peur encore aujourd'hui qu'il
vous arrive quelque chose oui bah en
fait c'est ce qui expliquait la
procureur malheureusement le cyber
harcèlement ne s'est pas
arrêté parce que bon voilà il a été il a
été mené par par enfin pour moi par le
rappeur Booba et qui a une masse de fans
et de de gens qui le suivent qui sont
très importants il y a 6 millions de
fans donc ça fait beaucoup de gens et
que il y a eu 28 personnes qui ont été
interpellées c'est un signal fort mais
il y en a beaucoup d'autres encore c'est
pas terminé et voilà donc oui on a on a
très peur d'ailleurs ça s'arrête pas
enfin vous pourrez le voir je vais je
suis là aujourd'hui il y aura des des
des gens sur Twitter qui vont encore
menacer et cetera et cetera c'est donc
l'éventualité de la prison ferme ça les
fait ça leur fait pas peur en fait je
pense que malheureusement ils ont pas
encore compris non ils ont pas compris
donc bah après j'ai envie de dire même
Booba qui a été placé misise en examen
placé sous contrôle judiciaire malgré le
contrôle judiciaire a quand même
continuer ces publications hein donc
donc mais c'est quand même des exemples
je pense votre avocat a dit que c'était
un vrai tournant ce ce procès qu' y
avait une vraie prise de conscience
parce que les réquisitions sont sont
fortes parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui qui sont à la barre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter un petit peu ce qui
a ce qui a ce qui comment elle qu'elle a
été sa pldoirie justement moi je je l'ai
ressenti que le tribunal était vraiment
très très à l'écoute du dossier et c'est
vraiment saisi du dossier ils sont
rentrés dans les détails ils ont pas
passé voilà c'est la procureur aussi
c'était vraiment pour moi un moment de
presque de renaissance c'était c'était
incroyable et puis on se rend compte
aussi du profil des cyberhceleurs on a
tendance à dire que le cyberhcèlement
est créé moi au début quand ça m'est
arrivé on disait mais n'écoute pas ce
sont des gamins et bien on s'aperçoit
que sur les 28 ce sont 28 adultes qui
ont entre 20 et 50 ans il y a pas eu un
seul mineur d'arrêté vous avez été
surprise par les les profilsou oui
complètement il y a sur les 28 26 hommes
et deux femmes ça ça envoie des des
signaux qui sont forts c'est 26 hommes
et deux femmes uniquement et puis les
écouter à la barre ça a été quelque
chose pour moi parce que alors malgré ça
il y a la moitié qui s'est présenté
l'autre moitié qui n'est pas venu quand
même mais la moitié qui se sont
présentés ont reconnu des choses je les
ai entendu reconnaître des choses
reconnaître des pardons demander des un
pardon rien que ça pour moi ça a été
quelque chose d'expliquer pourquoi même
s'il y a pas d'excuse rien ne justifie
ce qui s'est passé mais voilà j'ai
entendu des choses c'était des rumeurs
je me suis trompée je me suis trompée de
cible non je n'ai pas été arnaqué par
Magalie bardda et ça ça a été dit par
les 13 il y en a pas un seul qui a dit
j'ai été arnaqué au contraire ils ont
dit les 13 j'ai été influencé donc ça
représent quelque chose pour vous AZ
reçu plus de 100000 messages oui 100000
ouis oui globalement effectivement un
c'est excuse mais tous ont dit qu'ils
n'ont pas réalisé ce qu'il faisaient
est-ce que pour vous ça c'est une
manière d'alléger leur peine potentielle
ou est-ce que c'est vrai bien sûr c'est
une manière d'alléger la peine
potentielle parce que ça a été très bien
relevé par par la juge assesseur qui a
dit mais vous pouvez pas dire que vous
ne le saviez pas parce que moi je me
suis mise dans un je pense que vous le
savez tous ici je me suis vraiment
retranchée dans un dans une vie un peu
bizarre pendant cette année et demi où
je ne vivais qu'à travers ce
cyberhcèlement ma vie n'était faite que
de ça et donc les seules fois où je
reprenais mes réseaux sociaux alors
qu'avant j'étais vivante dessus enfin je
je je c'était mon travail hein et bien
c'était pour appeler à l'aide et la la
le le proc la procureur l'a dit et la
juge a dit c'estàdire que ces gens-là
ont réagi en me cberarcelant à des
appels à l'aide c'est-à-dire que des
fois je suppliais les gens d'arrêter et
à ça il me disait on ne te lâchera pas
on te traquera jusqu'à la mort on ne te
lâchera pas jusqu'à la fin tu on va on
va on va te finir c'est fini
et ça ne peut pas être pour moi anodin
parce que il réagissez à ce genre
de ça vous a fait beaucoup de mal
personnellement mais aussi
professionnellement je crois est-ce que
vous savez combien vous avez perdu à
cause de ce harcèlement en terme de
chiff d'affaires bah la
société alors la société SH Evens he
pour qui que j'ai fondé euh
effectivement a fait une chute libre de
30 millions d'euros sur une année vous
avez perdu 30 millions d'euros à cause
bah en fait il y a eu de la part de
Booba au début un appel un appel clair
hein au boycott c'est-à-dire que il a
affiché le les marques avec qui on
travaillait en disant tous ceux qui
travaillent avec Magalie Berda vont
avoir le droit à la malédiction et donc
il posta les comptes Instagram de toutes
les marques avec qui ont travaillit pour
que tous les trolls de Twitter aillent
allumer les marques donc les marques ce
que je peux comprendre elles payent pour
faire de la pub elle payent pas pour se
faire massacrer sur les réseaux et ça je
peux comprendre donc les marques bah on
est allé à reculon il y a ça et puis il
y a mon état moi j'étais aussi laffiche
de cette agence et c'est vrai que je
vivais à travers cette agence donc
j'étais plus en état non plus je ne je
ne j'ai perdu complètement le contrôle
de mon cerveau de mon état de de tout ce
qui m' arrivait c'était une perte de
contrôle totale donc quand vous avez ça
plus ça plus ça et puis les salariés
aussi qui ont pris aussi c'est c'est dur
il y a une personne qui a été
interpellée dans nos bureaux la police a
dû faire monter tous les salariés au
3ème étage pour faire une interpellation
en flagrant d'lit de tentative de
chantage cette personne va être jugée
d'ailleurs fin décembre aussi en plus
c'est traumatisant aussi pour une équipe
booba a posté une photo du nouveau
bureau parce qu'on a essayé d'aller
ailleurs pour sécuriser notre bureau et
les gens qui travaillent avec nous et
puis pour que moi aussi j'aille mieux il
a posté la la photo du bureau et et il y
a eu l'adresse qui a été divulguée alors
qu'on avait même pas encore fait le
changement au greffe et et on a été
cassé trois fois le bureau a été cassé
trois fois donc aujourd'hui je travaille
chez moi je suis condamnée pour
l'instant à travailler chez moi oui paka
alors moi je suis complèement contre
l'harcèlement et contre le cyber
harcèlement donc je pense pas que vous
méritiez de vous prendre des menaces de
mort ou des attaques sur votre famille
mais normement moi qui suis influenceux
je suis contre les placements de
produits frauduleux donc je peux
comprendre la colère des gens mais ça
n'a rien à voir en fait il y a eu des
contrôles de la répression des fraudes
sur la société il y a eu des demandes
qui ont été faites et à ce jour SH Evens
n'a été condam condamné à rien et ça il
faut le dire une bonne fois pour toutes
le procès qu'on m'a fait c'est un procès
médiatique et ça il faut le dire parce
que c'est une vérité non mais c'est une
vérité c'estd je pense que si vous avez
des gens à rembourser il faut les
rembourser mais je pense pas que vous
méritez l'arcèement mais alors déjà nous
on n pas un site internet moi je suis
pas un site internet je suis comme une
régie de pub 2.0 déjà mais il faut
vérifier parce que moi carrément même ma
petite sœur elle s'est fait arnaquer par
une de vos influenceuses Maeva GAM mais
je ne sais pas de quoi tu parles et
encore une fois mais je ne sais pas de
quoi tu parles et quand bien même je
vais texliquer quel quelque chose com
même il y a un site qui a fait une
dérive le site il a été contrôlé on
avait un service juridique en place qui
a été mis en place par banij qui a fait
le nécessaire le site avait été vérifié
si dedans il y a un site qui qui ça peut
arriver
sur excuse-moi sur 5000 sites avec qui
on a travailler s'il y en a quelquesuns
qui ont pas fait les choses correctement
alors dans ces cas-là il faut attaquer
ces sites là mais tu peux pas taler une
une personne qui a c'est pas possible en
fait et c'est pas la loi c'est et encore
une fois je le dis et je le redis dit
tous les les toutes les enquêtes pour
l'instant qui ont eu lieu n'ont donné
rien tu entends ça ou pas et ça c'est
important pour pour moi parce que c'est
c'est grave et on peut pas dire à une
personne je vais te décapiter à peu près
100 fois par jour et recevoir plus de
100000 messages j'ai en fait je suis pas
un criminel c'est sûr mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que les personnes qui
par exemple commandent VI vos
influenceurs ils connaissent pas
vraiment la marque ils vous font
confiance à vous ou à
l'influenceur merci d'être là Kim alors
Kim tu as accouché toi ça y est ça y est
tuas un polinel dans le tiroir et là
c'est bon euh tu ais pu me dire que j'ai
vite retrouvé la ligne quandême tuas
vite retrouvé la lig
merci Kim donc tuasas tu as une Fifi oui
euh elle a un mois ça va tu es contente
ouais c'est le bonheur c'est vrai tu tu
tu es en couple toi tu es oui je sa pas
pas trop la la vie des des Gabes en fait
donc ça va ça se passe bien oui le
bonheur absolu je va être plus heureuse
vraiment ouais et ben tu vas voir tu
seras moins heureuse après ce
débat non alors donc tamis Tami donc tu
as créé un compte insta pour ta fille
qui se rappelle tu peux nous rappeler
Talia Talia avec un contact pour des
contrats publicitaires alors qu'elle
était âgée que de 10 jours pourquoi vous
l'avez caché elle est magnifique ma
fille c'est une bombe atomique bah ouais
mais on on imagine elle est trop belle
mais tu veux qu'on a tu veux qu'on a des
tu veux qu'on a des des des bah oui ma
foi c'est une bombe je Chi de ma fille
ouais mais nous aussi mais c'est juste
des on a des consignes tu sais et ben je
vous autorise à montrer ma beauté c'est
vrai oui alors on va on va
merci il fait bien rire de l'in
insupportable j'adore j'adore j'adore
alors la question c'est êtes-vous choqué
pourquoi tu as fait ça alors pourquoi
j'ai fait ça parce que ben déjà comme je
viens de le dire ma fille c'est une
bombe et quand tu allumes la télé que tu
vois des bébés pour des couches je pas c
t les mar ou pour des des des ça ça
choque personne c'est comme ça moi
personnellement je veux le meilleur pour
ma fille et on sait pas de quoi demain
est fait je veux son que son avenir soit
en qu'elle soit en sécurité en fait et
moi je vois pas le mal j'ai pas fait ça
pour prendre des sous pour ma fille j'ai
pas besoin de ça moi je gagne ma vie de
mon côté c'est pour elle pour un compte
g dans ta vie tu gages dans ta vie
correctement genre combien alors quand
même on est pas là pour parler de ça
mais le truc c'est que moi j'ai fait
complément
d'enquê et d'ailleurs je te soutiens
team Cyril laissez-le tranquille
quoi
non mais blague à part je veux dire moi
si ma fille elle fait j'ai créé ça pour
qu'elle ait des contrats pour elle pour
son compte en banque pour qu'à 18 ans me
disent merci maman c'est pas pour moi
j'ai pas besoin de de ma fille pour
gagner ma vie c'est vraiment pour elle
pour pour une sécurité financière pour
son avenir je ne veux que son bonheurou
kou oui alors je ne suis pas choquée
pour moi Kim déjà c'est son business
elle est très d'ca oui on l'adore c'est
son business depuis 15 ans ça fait 15
ans qu'elle est sur Instagram sur les
réseaux c'est son travail c'est son G
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a des milieux
que certaines personnes peuvent moins
comprendre que d'autres donc ça je le
conçois après là le son bébé il est tout
petit il on le reconnaît pas dans la rue
c'est un petit bébé j'y vois aucun
problème comme elle a dit ça prépare son
avenir et cetera ce qui peut me me
chagriner un petit peu par la suite
c'est quand ton bébé on va pouvoir le
reconnaître dans la rue là il aura pas
choisi ton bébé c'est ça qui peut un peu
me perturber donc pourquoi pas stopper à
un moment donné quand tu vas commencer à
être un petit peu connu reconnu pour
protéger son intimité et lui peut-être
plus tard en grandissant il aura le
choix de reprendre son réseau social que
tu laisseras ouvert là je sais en plus
que généralement les gens le créent
assez tôt pour pas que le nom soit pris
et qu'il soit usurpé que justement on te
vole des photos et
cetera sur ça c'est que là je m'étais
dit de toute façon ma fille a les petite
je vais voir comment ça se passe et
c'est drôle parce qu'on en a pas parlé
mais je te rejoins là-dessus je métais
dit si si tu vois une fois qu'elle sera
reconnaissable je vais voir et je vais
aviser mais en fonction là en fait elle
est tellement belle je te jure je oui au
mme si elle était moche hein c'est comme
tous les parents veulent le meilleur
pour leurs enfants et moi vraiment je
l'ai fait en toute bienveillance et avec
tout mon amour et vraiment c'est je vois
aucun mal en ayant fait ça c'est
vraiment pour elle c'est pas pour me
faire du fric sur ma fille mais jamais
de la vie ouais qui c'est qui est choqué
là alors Gill ver 12 oui je suis déçu
non je suis déçu moi je suis déçu que tu
me soutiennent pas ouais mais je
comprends mais moi je suis déçu plutôt
que choqué parce que c'est dangereux ce
que vous faites tout simplement c'est
dangereux mais parce qu'on est avec des
psychopathes en France on doit plus rien
faire c'est plutôt au psychopathe de
c'est pas à nous tout suite tout de
suite j'ai j'ai même pas prononcé le mot
que vous l'avez dit les psychopathes les
réseaux pédophiles fait plus rien parce
qu' y a des gens traqués sur terre oui
eux de se contenir à tous ces pervers
mais comme comme vous êtes très
intelligente que vous le savez je n'ai
pas compris vos mots quand la petite est
née quand Alya est né c'était magnifique
je les ai lu bienvenue dans ce monde mon
amour tu es notre plus beau trésor et 10
jours après vous en faites c'est beau
ah c'est beau c'est de l'amour d'une
mère excuse-moi ah et moi ça m'a ému je
suis un cœur d'Ar vous m'avez ému et là
et là ça me déçoit parce que vous en
faites une activité mercantile vous
dites j'ai pas besoin de garnir mon
compte en banque mais réseau contrat
publicitaire on le voit derrière Cyrille
c'estàdire que vous en faites une vous
en faites une activité économique non
elle en aura pas besoin laissezla
choisir ne l' moi aujourd'hui Gill je
gagne ma vie mais qu'est-ce que j'en
sais que je la gagnerai dans dans 5 ans
dans z ass pour vivre toute une
vie elle pas ass qu'estce que tu
raconteselle gagnenormément
d'Ar et tant mieux pour
elle petite balle perdue comme ça ça
fait du bien ça fait toujours
plaisir fais gaffe alors je tiens à dire
aussi c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
d'influenceuses qui me contactent
actuellement depuis le complément
d'enquête sachez que il faut arrêter de
m'appeler mot je suis raide je n'ai pas
d'oseille voilà c'était que des
conneries donc arrêtez parce que c'est
vrai que tu tu en fait tu dis que
arrêtez avec ça vous êtes beaucoup plus
riche que moi ok tu gages combien tu
gagnes combien mais je non on n pas là
et toi tu gagnes combieni on l'a dit
combien de c'est des conneries c'est des
conneries ce qu'ils ont dit c'est non
mais
voilà je je vois ce que tu veux dire
mais en même temps on fait plus rien
parce que le monde est rempli de fou tu
vois ce que je veux dire et moi je
trouve c'est pas con ce qu'elle dit non
mais c'est jamais con ce qu'elle dit bah
oui bien sûr en revanche non non
oui j'an oui non mais je trouve ça
ahurissant déjà on est en 2024 bientôt
2024 wake up tu vois et
voilà les trèsô leurs enfants au milieu
du cinéma les chanteurs emmènent leurs
enfants au concert et ils sont dans
milieu du cinéma elle est influenceuse
son enfant certainement TR très rapid
confronté au milieu des influenceurs de
la mode des promotion et ben je vois pas
problème mais elle alors justement elle
qu'estce qu'est-ce qu'elle risque et tu
dis les pédophil et les pédophile
s'attaquent aux gens qui sont sur les
réseaux il s'attaquent comme ça
malheureusement au hasard de
fantas et
même c'estueulasse tu as fait une pu
pour les crayons qu couleurs mais AR
conneries c'estme 50 % des photos et des
vidéos qui sont sur les sites pédopraphi
ont été prises sur les compes des
parents pé ex avant les
réseauit just elle dit un truc vra elle
dit à là moi je suis là pour l'encadrer
et laéger ni des réauxx moi je préfère K
qui le fait ouvertement et qui encadre
sa fille dès la naissance plutôt que de
voir des petits de 10 ans qui ont déjà
tous Instagram TikTok et cetera qui
tombent sur des trucs de dingue tous les
jours des gens à poil de la pornographie
de la violence et ben je préfère qu'elle
crée un compte elle-même et qu'elle le
gère elle-même pour sa propre fille
plutôt que laisser les gosses de 89 ans
à faire des choses euê d'accord toi
c'est l'hpocrisie
V
toujoursit je cont par candid dansmion
an qu'est-ce qu'on en a à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Buss non non pas du tout c'est
une bonne avouer non ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que c'est que K à la base
ne voulait pas d'enfant elle voulait
absolument pas d'enfant je trouve que
c'est magnifique ce qui t'arrive tu as
un enfant bravo tu la G très très bien
petit bémol a il y a comment s'appelle
il y a
Mo au
collège à
cé occupes très très bien ça fait 4
semaines elle dort elle boit du
lait et
alors non
plus pris trois photos sur instaê trop
bêt les
gar juste pour finir voilà fais
attention dark web voilà tout simplement
effectivement parfois il y a des dérives
et qu'il faut faire attention mais bravo
c'est bien
voilà oui moi je je vais casser
l'ambiance comme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'habitude
[Applaudissements]
bienmissionich al il a le triangle
triangle ah j'ai envie ch Géraldine le
triangle desas a chanté j'ai envie
de je vous trouve très sympathique et
j'espère que votre présent ce soir c'est
pas parce queussi vous êtes harcelé sur
les réseaux parce qu'on vous critique et
moi je déteste qu'on voilà qu'on qu'on
menace les gens qu'on intimide les gens
cont commeité de de justifier pourquoi
d'accord donc c'est très bien donc en
revanche moi effectivement je vais
apporter des petites des petites
remarques et voilà moi j'aime pas parce
que je trouve qu'en fait votre bébé il a
rien demandé alors certes c'est votre
bébé mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
votre chose c'est votre V accessoire
c'est une sorte de filon commercial et
j'ai l'impression que vous l'utilisez il
y a un côté pour moi je sais pas
proxénétisme numérique quand vous
allumez la télé vous voyez un bébé vous
vous dites bah ses parents l'utilisent
pourant il est dans un film dans une
publicit je dis pas c'est le bébé de
kunglo alors que là je sais que c'est
votre bébé voyez parce que vous vous
êtes très connu donc vous êtes médiatisé
on sait qui vous êtes et donc on sait
que c'est votre bébé que vous utilisez
et que vous monétisez et moi ça ça me
déplaît parce que le bébé comme l'a dit
très justement Kelly tout à l'heure bon
ok peut-être que là pour le moment elle
n'est pas traumatisée elle le vivra bien
mais peut-être qu'à 10 ans elle aima pas
que sa maman l' utilisé onè son insta et
en 2 mois plus personne se rappelle d'
mais non parce que justement il y a vous
savez très bien vous connaissez beaucoup
mieux insta que moi vous savez très bien
que la mémoire numérique elle part
jamais il y a une question il y a une
question de quelqu'un j'aimerais bien
savoir si cyil tu mettrais ta fille sur
internet pour y vendre des produits quel
qu'il soit C non bon pour vous non voilà
voilà qui qui mettrait ici
non et donc vous dites que l'argent il
est bloqué l'argent il est bloqué pour
sur un pour l'instant j'ai rien fait
hein mais moi j'aimerais qu' qu'elle par
dans un film dans des publicités c'est
pour elle pour ça serait chaque centime
serait pour ma fille parce que vous
savez que c'est la jurisprudence Jordi
qui est un un jeune qui chantait à
l'époque vous étiez peut-être pas né et
bref l'argent était bloqué jusqu'à
justement ses parents avaient pris
l'argent qu'il avait gagné et il s'est
retrouvé ruiné donc là vous me confirmez
que donc vous vous avez BL moi c'est
vraiment je je je suis une stressée de
la vie je ne sais pas de quoi demain est
fait et si vous avez besoin d'argent
énormément dans 5 ans vous êtes dans la
merde alors vous allez prendre l'argent
vous Vêtre F a gagner grâce à d' je veux
savoir non mais il y av il y avait une
alternative c'était mettre dans une
vraie agence de pub le bébé
AG dire un truc j'ai juste un truc à
vous dire occupez-v de votre
C fait j'avais une
répup'up son instagram sur la vitrine
pour faire des dansp tellement vous êtes
vieux
jeo truc que tuas jamais fait tu peux
parler ou alors on parle plus chacun
parle plus de ça l'argument j'ai pas
d'enfant ça m'éve non mais moi de mon
temps il y avait des des des magazines
avec les petits enfants et j'ai reproché
tout le temps à ma maman j'étais super
mignonne quand j'étais petite je lui ai
reproché commir oui mais une agence de
pub c'était dans les années excuse-moi
je suis n en 1963 maintenant c'est ça
quand tu vois non mais vous voyez toutes
les horreurs qu'il y a sur les réseau
phot ferme s'il vous plaît merci merci 8
télpectateur les gens ils donnent des
leçons mais je suis désolée moi j'ai pas
il y a vas-y je vais me taire parce
qu'après je vais encore me prendre une
PO sur le dos alors qu'est-ce que tu
veux
dire je veux dire il y a pas de sa
métier dans la vie vraiment je suis
personne mais j'ai envie qu'elle ait un
bel avenir j'ai envie que que quand
qu'elle ait toutes les clés pour faire
tout ce qu'elle veut faires elle a le
temps elle a le Time qu'elle aille à
l'école elle a le Time voilà j'ai tu tu
aimerais qu'elle fasse quoi ta fille
plus tard ce qu'elle veut franchement ce
qui la rend heureuse
vraimentou si elle a envie d'être pilote
de Formule 1 mais je veux qu'elle ait
l'argent pour se payer des cours de
pilote de Formule 1 d'accord voilà tout
simplement qu'elle fasse ceelle veut
travailler à l'hôtel Formule 1
elle fera ce qu'elle veut sa jamais atts
moi je l'encadrerai je la soutiendrai
pour qu'elle réalise ses rêves et
qu'elle soit du moment qu'elle a l'amour
de ses parents qu'elle est encadrée
qu'on la soutient c'est tout ce qui
compte je veux que son bonheur et j'ai
pas compris cette polémique et les gens
qui font les choqués j'aimerais bien
voir ce qu'ils font avec leurs enfants
en fait bla bla bla ça parle mais
derrière tu sais ce qu'ils font il leur
ouvre un compte à côté il durement
il ouv un compte si j'ai pas envie
qu'elle travaille durement etelle arrive
son c'est ch tu veux fouten comm oui je
travaille
durement-ce qu'il a dit j'ai pas
entendu que tu veux que ta fille ne
foute rien comme toi et qu' se réveille
tous les matins comme toi coucou les
loulous est-ce que tu connais pouris
jeenou paramètre ça trouu dans
tu me connais pour dire que je fa rien
qu'est-ce que tu sais de que je fais de
mes journé les autres gens parce que moi
j'ai pas pour moi influenceur comme le
fait faut se lever le matin et ê dégoûté
de se lever pour dire qu'on travaille
durement ouis je me lève avec le sourire
en fait et ma fille je veux qu'elle se
lève avec le sourire en fait pourquoi me
lever oh je vais au travail
aujourd'hui je suis
dégoûté g les gens ouvrent des compes
parce que tu dis comment ils font les
gens bon là les mec je suis pressé j'ai
20h50
press ça va calme-toi ma ch
as rien à car ah oui non Mo l'essentiel
c'est que ma fille soit heureuse voilà
oui tu habites où toi qu'on sou dans le
sud de la France et ben tu retournes
dans le sud ta fille elle est où avec
son papa sud de la France avec son papa
elle est heureuse là ça nous a fait PL
de Mar pas tu étais pas dans le dans
l'émission de moonere toi ouour sur l'
de colanta il m'a formé Mia dur non en 2
jours allez ouais
2 jours sans manger sans
manger mais t'ont pas demandé de
travailler làb
qume et là tu travailles toi ce
soir moi faut venir à 5h du matin à
l'heure où tu vas te coucher qu moi ris
pas moi à 5 si tu veux me voir
travailler c'est à 5h tu peux
venir
5 merci les chér va passer à Michel
Marie tu connais mich Mar allez couche
bah oui cou je VO bienelle
là j'ai pas fait de nuit depuis un mois
je suis très content de le
savoir V te reposer ce soir tu vas te
reposer ce soir Kim oui là tu dors toute
seule tranquille là tu vas pouvoir
profiter 7h j'ai laavion demain matin
écoute si tu veux m'écrire ta vie tu me
l'as mets
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là mais j'adore j'adore ils se sont bien
occupés de toi tuev nous voir quand tu
veux tu sais qu'on t'adore ici ou moi je
t'adore après voilà DISI non j'ai adoris
quand a chanté tout à l'heure
comm comment termine sur une bonne note
moi je suis toujours content de te voiri
ai et tu t'en fous de ce que disent les
gens fa que tu ah mais complètement moi
je pense à l'avenir de ma fille je veux
juste qu'elle soit heureuse le ouais
fais ta vie tu t'en fous sans rigoler
voilà continue t'emmerd pas fais des
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
brushings
[Applaudissements]